you welcome to this video playing hope
said no tokelau everything I can what
kind of flag is that ok playing joke or
Y open and what do we get here probably
some kind of maroc see bite yr
transposition ok still think that might
be the result of that no it's not taking
oh I'd like to play the maracas see so
please take he doesn't ok yeah i think
i'm going to go for for the advance wow
really aren't you just going back now if
i go here no he's not going back you can
actually do Jeff for hmm yeah I wanted
to go night in one first and I thought
why not to detune this is why how stupid
that's stupid night h5 is really sorry
it's really a silly me and I really
played it like it makes lots of sense
now like 91 would be just good for white
he has to go back and i go to d three or
so but yeah the 92 is a ridiculous reply
what I played them ok I don't think it's
that bad now it's possible to go a
five-year hoon happy to take that space
in g4 is a move but i think i'm going to
start with that also attacking these six
yes yeah i was thinking Bishop g5 might
be interesting just set up this pin
Bishop f5 is unplayable I think you two
look f1 and that pin is super annoying I
mean I really don't see how he gets out
of it
yeah but it doesn't really help i can i
can improve here this improve this
position and will let's say he cannot do
anything i can take these six now then
one day I should do that yeah it's a
very very important point so let's take
the pawn black resigns yeah yeah that
was there was a rather unplayable
position after at five I think at least
how it how it evolved at the end but 92
was was was immensely silly yeah that
night h5 is just this is just miss
placing this piece I can ignore it but
originally I wanted to do this which
sends him back and then this is just
losing time and I have this F for a
possibility now I can reroute the night
decently while you just has lost time
but then I thought I why do you want
wine or TI ya this is why so it is very
bad i came i played this maybe I'm
getting in Bishop f1 and I can send him
back that was my idea but ok can just
take of course and this seems fine no be
6v6 is kind of unclear what it
accomplishes because he never wants to
fianchetto anyway ok when f1 and he went
5 and now f5 the end I think here around
here he has to improve because this this
fields fields almost unplayable yeah the
engine agrees it's on about plus 1 now
yeah thing is I'm getting this e
foursquare I get this pin if possible
and I have G for a king edge 1g4 with a
with already made attack while this
Bishop is just very stupid piece and
after King age ain't no is winning here
plus 2 this is a deadly pen he cannot
get out of it
this okay the engine already gives this
move intend a queen h3 h4 valises even
more straightforward and really doesn't
matter Black is completely tied down I
have all the time in the world and now I
took 26 it's not really necessary but I
mean after something like rook f3 rook
f1 rook h3 I mean what is black doing
you just can never move any of those
pieces but I think 96 should be pretty
convincing yeah here is right now this
hangs and I'm just threatening out to go
back and re-establish that point yeah
it's a bit strange he very quickly
decided on I think five seconds for the
losing move no well it's the old story I
really think if they if you change the
structure very innovating a very very
committal way you should take a little
bit more time than five seconds for that
especially if you add on the clock after
that you're not coming back from from
this now i'm not sure what you should do
because white is probably better anyway
the engines suggests this funky move we
don't understand that wants to go to h5
maybe now yeah I prefer white it because
of the space but it's not it's not the
end of the world ok well thanks for
watching